Users often decide whether
to install an app based
on its Play Store
listing, so you
need to make sure you have
the best possible listing
for your app.
I'm Kobi, from the
Google Play team,
and I'm going to
tell you how you
can experiment with the text and
graphics of your app's listing
on Google Play, with our new
Store Listing Experiments
feature.
You can use data,
instead of intuition,
to optimize your store
listing, increasing
the number of visitors to
your page who actually convert
and install your app.
There's no coding required.
All you need is someone who can
create graphics and write text.
For example,
Kongregate, creators
of the popular
game "Epic Skater,"
created four versions of
the app icon for their game.
They tested the icon with
Store Listing Experiments,
and found that the
best icon is improving
install rates by more than 39%.
Starting today, you too
can run your own test
to see what changes
drive the most installs.
First, log into the Google
Play Developer Console.
Under Store Listing, go to
the new Experiments page.
There, you can
create an experiment
with up to three variants of
your app's text and graphics.
You can decide how
many users will
see each of these variants.
You may want to start your
experiments on a small group
of users, such as 10%.
You can run two
types of experiments.
Global, which will
pertain to all users.
And localized, which
will pertain to users
of a specific language.
In global experiments, you
can only change the graphics,
while in localized
experiments you
can change the graphics or
text for a particular language.
Go to the Developer Console
to track your experiments.
Once we've gathered enough data,
you will see the conclusion,
and you can apply the winning
variant as your store listing.
So how do you optimize
your Store Listing?
We found that store
listing pages perform best
when they clearly
highlight value to users.
An app description should
be clear and to the point.
For example, an app
description like,
photo editor producing
professional results,
works better than,
an awesome app
where you have fun with photos.
You can also use Store
Listing Experiments
to gain insight into users, and
how they think about your app.
For example, do users prefer
to think of your game as one
with beautiful and
realistic graphics, or one
with exciting action game play?
As you've seen
before, icons matter,
so make sure they're of
high quality and beautiful.
Choose the app screenshots
carefully, and experiment
with their order,
we found it matters.
Be bold, try things.
Don't assume your store
listing is good enough.
But at the same time, remember
that not all experiments
will increase your
app's install rate.
The developers of
the app EverythingMe
wanted to test two hypothesises.
That their app icon
should be more colorful,
and that the letters "me"
do not work well globally.
Take a look at their
experiment, which
confirmed both
hypothesis, and allowed
them to change their
icon, improving
install rates by more than 33%.
Optimizing your Store
listing is perhaps
the most important thing you
can do for your app acquisition,
because it affects traffic
coming from all sources.
It amplifies organic
user acquisition
in Google Play, as well as
your own marketing efforts.
Well, good luck, and
we hope you enjoy
optimizing your Store listing.